so what was the very first thing that
someone said Ryan I think you said it
was curved curved not straight that's
very important help me out what else did
we say okay we said there is symmetry
along the y axis mm-hmm what else I
think Ryan was talking about the fact
that it it looks like a straight line if
you go far enough the way that we would
say that is it approaches a linear
function that's a really fancy way to
say it we'll come back to these words
next term but all that means is if you
look far enough at a particular spot it
looks like a straight line were there
any other features that we noted any
other features let me add one or two
more some really important ones okay you
know how the number line has one
important spot on it that's more
important than the rest and the
Cartesian plane also has an important
spot that spot is very important to the
parabola as well do you notice that it's
the spot where it it sort of turns
around it's where it curves right well
it sort of curves everywhere this is
where it goes from down to up okay so
that's what has a name it's called the
vertex the vertex okay the vertex of
this particular parabola because there's
others we're going to explore a second
so the vertex of this parabola is 0 0
the origin okay all right now we're
going to play with this a little bit if
you have an already open your laptop
back up this is going to get a little
bit busier so what I'm going to ask you
to do is we've got y equals x square
there use all these other X's use them
to get rid of all the other stuff okay
we just want y equals x squared so I'm
going to delete all these things
okay so now we've just got this guy what
I want you to do is click into the
actual equation up here and in front of
the X I want you to put the letter A and
you can just type a or you can use your
own skiing keyboard now when you do that
does your screen do what my train did
it's an ad flight go ahead press the
blue button okay now what you've added
is as the name suggests it's a slider so
you go ahead and slide this thing around
okay I'm going to be super lazy I'm
going to get it to slide itself okay now
what's happening what's happening yeah
okay let's slow this down it's going a
bit too fast for my liking that's a bit
too slow okay what's going on what's
going on I'm going to stop it let's stop
it about well do actually I want to do
one more thing can you add on x squared
again you know how you changed your x
squared I need you to add on x squared
just add it back okay okay maybe I'll
make it a bit of a simpler number let's
go to like three or something then okay
what you're looking at right now is y
equals x squared next to one of its
cousins it's y equals at the moment a my
aunt I love you to put yours the same as
mine a is three right now so this is y
equals three x squared
okay how would you describe the
difference between y equals x squared
which is my green one and y equals three
x squared which is my black one what's
different it's yeah it looks like it's
kind of narrower narrower okay but there
are most of the things that are still
the same aren't they have a look at this
list that we wrote down how many of
these things are still the same we wrote
down four things how many of them are
still the same of this
they're all the same in fact okay it's
still curved they're still the same
symmetry it's still if you zoom in that
is what you choose and still look like a
straight line and it still has the same
what's that called again the vertex okay
good now I want you to take that three
right you can see obviously you can drag
it as far as you like you can slide as
far as you like and we'll keep on
getting steeper and steeper and steeper
by default it maxes out at 10 but if you
click on 10 you can actually change it
to be you can go from up to 100 if you
want or whatever you want and you can
see if I drag it look what happens it
just gets thinner and thinner and
thinner and there's no there's no limit
to it if I made it something like a
million y equals a million x squared
instead of just x squared it'd be like
is tiny speaker okay so I'm just going
to go back to the numbers that it was
before because they were fine okay now
we made it narrower but you guys noticed
what happened if I go to about there
what does this mean this is not y equals
3x squared it's y equals zero point
three x squared so how'd it different
now the black one is the change one
right say it again injury it's wider we
got an arrow before surprise surprise
this is wider it's wider because this
number is less than one if you put on
exactly one you just get the green graph
if you make it bigger than one you get
the narrower one does that make sense
okay and then you all notice when you
okay when it goes negative what happens
it's flipped down okay so we need to add
a little dot point on here to describe
this here we go parabolas parabolas they
can be a colloquial word would be facing
but a technical word is concave up or
concave down now you guys have met the
word concave before in science I'd guess
what do you usually describe concave
things as lenses glasses right you've
got concave you also have convex right
so here concave refers to which which
direction is the inside of I guess if it
was like a cop like a goblet of some
words that that's concave up this guy is
concave down okay they can be concave up
or concave down depending on okay now
again I need to introduce a new word I'm
sorry to introduce lots of terminology
for you but it's really important see
this number a out here it's oh it's so
close well actually it is a constant but
in this case because attached to an X a
variable we call it the coefficient so
if the coefficient is positive like a
equals three or a equals one or a equals
a thousand right if a is positive that's
how I would like that that means it's
concave up and maybe you want to draw
like a little tiny concave up parabola
here just so you remember what concave
up means
OOP there we go doesn't have to be big
or beautiful just so you can see the
direction if on the other hand like the
one I've got right now see that one over
there what is a it's negative one point
four so if a is negative then you get
concave down and again just draw a tiny
little diagram on the side there
just so you have a visual marker of what
concave down means
this is what happens when a is positive
or a is negative what happens when a is
neither positive nor negative
what's the number that's neither is zero
well go ahead make a equal zero oh it's
not a parabola at all right why is that
well now you've got y equals zero times
x squared well zero times anything is
still zero and that's that's that
straight line see that okay one last
thing we're going to do see how you've
got a x squared and I asked you to add
on the a I want to trick you add on
something different this time add on at
the end plus and then the letter C you
might think the noise logical thing to
add is a B but we'll come back to the B
in a minute
just make it a sin just like we did
before go ahead and add a slider okay
what just happened can you do me a favor
and make your numbers the same as mine
okay so I've got a is 1 and C is 1 okay
when a equals 1 this is just y equals x
squared but C is this number on the end
so this is y equals x squared plus 1 do
you see that it's plus 1 okay so what's
the difference between the black and the
green grass it's it's gone up right the
word the fancy where rule uses it's been
translated or shifted exactly the same
shape and I'm taking it up and you can
go ahead do this right now go ahead and
slide C change the value of C and see
what happens right see what happens so
anyway okay so when you let C slide up
and down right then literally the
parameter goes up and down okay so I'm
going to stop it around there I didn't
stop it earlier that elute okay come
back to the list come back to these
characteristics how many of these are
still true for the new one that we just
drew is it still curved yes
is it still got that symmetry yes does
it still do this straight-line thing if
you zoom in yes is the vertical zero
zero a half so the vertex can move up
and down you can put it wherever you
like okay depending on whatever C is in
fact if you look closely see that 3.92
have a look at where the vertex is on
line just below 4 no coincidence that's
three point nine two okay and of course
you go ahead and do this on your own one
if you drag it down put it some nice
number that you can see like minus two
then of course there it is right there
negative two